hey new girl everybody in this room is
about that superhero life and if you
don't mind my asking where the hell have
you been all this time
there are a lot of other planets in the
universe and unfortunately they didn't
have you guys
[Music]
well that's a scene from Avengers in
game after the film stunning debut had
earned a record 1.2 billion dollars
worldwide in its opening weekend it may
feel like the summer movie season is
already in full swing but it's just
getting started and plenty of other big
films are on the way here to tell us
what to look out for is Matt singer
editor-in-chief of the movie website
screen crush com Matt good morning good
morning
so is it looking like Walt Disney is
taking over here because you have the
Avengers in game the re-release of The
Lion King
Aladdin and even Toy Story yes so the
the fourth biggest animated movie of all
time is the original Lion King the fifth
biggest is Toy Story 3 and in the span
of a month Disney is releasing new
versions of both of those movies you
look incredible the Lion King there with
these incredible modern special effects
a cast that includes donald glover and
beyonce well so that's gonna make I
think it's gonna do okay let's put it
that way the month before that you have
Toy Story 4 that's got you know Woody
and Buzz and the new toy for ki
literally a plastic fork parents get
ready to buy plastic pork it's a sport
on yes yes that's the box off prediction
for that one as well and Aladdin a
live-action version of Aladdin with Will
Smith as the genie and yeah they've got
this little art house hit kind of
touring the the world right now called
Avengers endgame that's doing okay yeah
they just bought Fox so they have an
x-men movie coming out too and it really
is the summer of Disney the year of
Disney the foreseeable future of Disney
so knows something as we move away from
Disney internet buzz right now is about
bright Bernal yeah about a little
different yeah this has a great premise
this is like what if there was a kid
just like Superman but instead of kind
of growing up in this family and
becoming a hero who fights for truth
justice the American Way he becomes a
sociopath and he fights for evil and
mayhem and sadistic murder it's produced
by James Gunn who we now know for
superheroes guardians of the galaxy but
he really got to start doing horror
movies so this is kind of a
interesting combination of the two and
that idea Superman kind of grows up to
be a slasher movie villain I think
that's an ingenious premise so that
looks really that is a twist on the
formula yes a film that I'm really
looking forward to is something called
yesterday that's from Danny Boyle the
director of Slumdog Millionaire that's
right this one it's it's about a
struggling musician played by him ash
Patel he gets bumped on the head he has
this accident and when he wakes up
nobody but him in the entire world
remembers the Beatles so when he plays a
Beatle song everyone's like wow this is
a great song I wrote it and he becomes
like a world-famous musician playing
Beatles songs so yeah Danny Boyle who
did Slumdog Millionaire and
Trainspotting and it's also written by
Richard Curtis who did nodding he'll so
a great combination and even in the
worst case scenario even if it's a
disaster you still have the Beatles oh
yeah really good that's right you got
director Quentin Tarantino has been
absent for four years he has this new
film once upon a time in Hollywood how's
that expected to do oh I think this one
could be big as well so you know like
every Quentin Tarantino movie has lots
of references to old movies and he shows
this one is really the first that's
about old movies and TV shows you have
Leo DiCaprio Brad Pitt they play a
western TV star and his stunt double and
they somehow get mixed up with the
Manson Family though so you have this
interesting blend of fact in fiction you
can see the period details look amazing
I'm really excited really Quentin
Tarantino taking on Charles Manson
that's really interesting yes we also
haven't we were talking music a minute
ago but the bio film music bio film
Rocket Man yes Elton John and we were
saying we had Bohemian Rhapsody this
might be a little bit different but we
don't know
yes Rocket Man even the biopics sound
like superhero movies when they come out
in the summer Rocket Man but yeah this
is the Elton John film and turn Edgerton
plays Elton John the kind of big
difference between this and Bohemian
Rhapsody is Taron Egerton actually does
his own singing if you like google it
you look it up on YouTube you can she's
finds him singing with Elton John he's
done some performances with him and he
sounds great it looks yeah it looks good
I mean everyone loves Elton John just
for the music alone that's right again
just for the music alone and out his
fuse up there alone yeah we got a zombie
movie coming
with weight Bill Murray Oh Murray Adam
driver Chloe Sevigny Tilda Swinton the
dead don't die this one couldn't be the
sleeper hit of the summer for me just an
amazing cast great premise horror and
comedy it's the walking dead Pam that's
my quick pitch for that one horror
comedy and it's from Jim Jarmusch a
great indie director who really excels
at making quirky genre films I can't
wait for that I love the comedy with
that yeah it's too scary I don't want to
see it alright I'm good thanks okay I've
sold haven't really looking forward to
now summer we'll go we'll make a group
outing